YOU SIR FOR JOINING US.
>> MERCEDES I'LL SEND IT OVER
TO YOU. IT IS LUCKY NUMBER 7
FOR THE GOLDEN TEE KEY THE LAS S
VEGAS STAPLE IS  CELEBRATING G
THEIR 7TH ANNIVERSARY WITH 7
DAYS OF FUN PLUS A WORLD
RECORD ATTEMPT HERE TO TELL US
MORE IS THEIR BEVERAGE
DIRECTOR.
>> A FABULOUS ADAM RAINS
LOOKING BACK. THANK YOU IT'S
GREAT TO BE BACK SO GOOD TO
HAVE YOU CONGRATULATIONS ON 7
YEARS THAT IS NOT SURPRISING
BECAUSE THE GOLDEN TAKE IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE BEST
PLACES TO CELEBRATE ANYTHING
HERE IN TOWN TELL US WHAT YOU
GUYS HAVE GOING ON.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE EXCITING
WEEK WE EVERY NIGHT WE HAVE 7
NIGHTS A FESTIVAL CELEBRATING
ALL THE 7 YEARS LIKE YOU
MENTIONED, SO TONIGHT WE'RE
DOING OUR FEDS NIGHT SO WE
HAVE MORE DATA IN OUR NEW HOW
DO I GET ONE OF THOSE ARE
SHOULD COME
IN TONIGHT, OKAY, I'LL DO THAT
SIP ON ATC LOCATION LISTEN AND
THEY'LL BE RIGHT THERE FOR YOU R
OK WE'LL TWEAKING OF TASTY
LIKE PATIENTS, YOU LDGUYS ARE
ATTEMPTING TO BREAK A WORLD
RECORD. NOW WHAT DOES THIS
TELL US MORE SO WE ARE WE ARE
SO THAT WILL BE THE
CULMINATION OF ALL 7 DAYS IN
EVERY BY THE WAY WAEVERWAY DAY
HAVE LIVE MUSIC CAN MEND
DEEJAYS AND ALL TYPES OF
EVENTS BUT THE COMBINATION IS IS
WORLD MIGHT HIDE A. NEXT
TUESDAY AND GOING TO BE THE
WORLD'S LARGEST MIGHT CAN YOU
SHOW ME HOW TO MAKE ONE SALUTE
WON'T BE THE WORLD'S LARGEST,
BUT THIS WILL BE THE WORLD'S
MADE LET'S MAKE IT HAPPEN ALL
RIGHT MICHAEL MY TIES, I LOVE
MY TIES WHAT HE GOT HERE SO
THIS ONE IS A VERSION OF THE
1944 TRADER PI CK  STYL E MY
TIME, OKAY WHICH IS
WONDERFULLY A IT'S A TART HAS AS
A LITTLE BIT TART SWEET.
STRONG A LITTLE BIT OF
EVERYTHING OK LOOKING FOR
SOUTH WHAT WAS THIS FRESH LIME
VERY VERY Y OMINOUS LOOKING INY
MAKE THERE I LOVE IT AND THEY
WILL DO OR SHOT WHICH IS AN
ALMOND FLOUR ORANGE. ALL
ORANGE FLOWER SYRUP OK THIS
WAS MEANT ADDRESS A DRINK HERE
LOCALLY FOR US I LOVE IT. I
HAVE THE E ORE IGINAL VERSION H
AN ORANGE CURTIS THIS IS AN
ITALIAN IAORANGE LIQUEUR THESE
ARE PRETTY POTENT LOOKS LIKE
THINGS THERE'S GOING TO SOME
THINGS HAPPENING HERE THE
ORIGINAL VERSION YOU CANNOT
REALLY MAKE IT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T MAKE THE ORIGINAL ROUND
WHICH IS LIKE A 17 AREA AGED
JAMAICAN ROB OKAY SO TO TO PUTT
THE JAMAICAN ICPOT STILL IN
THERE. WE HAVE A LITTLELI BIT O
SMITH ACROSS WE JUST PUT A
COUPLE BAR SPOON JUST A TINY
LIVES THAT ASKED A LITTLE OK
BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY POTENT
BOTH IN FLAVOR AND ALCOHOL
CONTENT OF THE BLUE TO SOME
PEOPLE WHALET YOLEU GOT GOING O
RE WONDERFUL AND THEN NEXT
WE HAVE ANAV AGAVE PUERTO ROME
FINALLY AN AGE VENEZUELAN
AROUND JUST AND POTS TONIGHT
BRINGS A LOT OF FLAVOR TO THE
PART OF THE SMELL JUST I'M
FEELING LIKE JUST BEACH OF
IV'S RIGHT NOW IT SMELLS SO
GOOD ABSOLUTELY SO LET'S SHAKE
IT UP PUT A LITTLE BIT ICE IN
THERE AND SHAKE OR I LOVE THE
SHAKE THAT'S MY FAVORITE PART.
HE DID WITH SUCH GRACE IS
THERE LIKE A SHAKING SCHOOL
YOU GO TO FOR YOU SORT OF IT
EVERY NIGHT AT THE GOING TO
HEAR A STEAK AND SHAKE AND SAY
I LOVE IT BUT THERE'S ACTUALLY
COMPLETE BOOKS WROKITTEOKN OKOK
HEY LET'S SAY ALL RIGHT SO
WE'RE JUST GOING TO WORLD.
POUR IT DIRECTLY IN THERE THAT
DOUBT IT WITH AS MUCH. ICE HAS
BEEN DAYS SO THE ICE IS THE
GOAL OF THE 2 OF SERIOUS
APPELLAPATE EYES MAKES ALL THE
DIFFERENCE. ABSOLUTELY SEE
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO IS YOU
WANT TO GET THAT ICE CROWN SO SO
IT INFL ATES  THE   CO CKTA  L
MAKES A KECOLDER COCK TAIL IS A
BETTER CAUGHT I BELIEVE THAT
WE ALL CAN AGREE RIGHT. YES S
FOR SURE AND THEN YOU JUST
WHAT DID YOU DO WITH THE MEN
TO THE WE BLESSED BLESSED A
COCKTAIL, BUT YOU REALLY IS
GETTING THE OILS ALL OVER
THAT. YOU KNOW SEEMS SOME
PEOPLE DO THE SLAP YEAH, WHICH
IS GREAT, BUT I CEMENT OILS ON
HAND I SMELL IT THOUGH YES
THIS WHOLE ALL RIGHT WE'VE 20
SECONDS ALL RIGHT SO THEN WE
HAVE ONLINE AND E WILLE  DO E L
CHERRY JUST FOR THE THE COLOR
AND THEN WE HAVE ONE OF OU R
GOLDEN TEE CUSTOM GLASS
STRAWS, OK SO PEOPLE WANT TO
BE A PART OF THIS BIG
ANNIVERSARY CELEBRATION WHERE
CIVIL THE TIKI AND WHEN DOES
IT TONIGHT RIGHT ARTS TONIGHT
COOLING TAKE TA
A
TAHE'STA INTA CHTAINATTAOWN TAO
MOUNTAIN  AND WE YOU CAN COME
FOR OUR NEW MIGHT 7TH
ANNIVERSARY MIGHT EYEGLASSES
ADAM THAT IS FABULOUS I'M
THERE AND I'M GOING TO
TONIGHT, WE'RE ONE OF THE
FENCES. ABSOLUTELY THIS
ALLOWED THIS IS WE'RE READY
READY TO CELEBRATE.